[MUSIC PLAYING]
Thank you for betting with
Google and thank you for
supporting us.
We want to empower people to
use technology, naturally.
One million new Android devices
are activated every
single day.
Android 4.1, Jelly Bean.
[APPLAUSE]
Now you might be asking-- well,
Nick, what comes next?
And the answer there
lies in mobile.
We have more people
using Google+ for
mobile than from desktop.
Are we going to get a native
tablet version of Google+?
Well, your answer is, you're
going to get it today.
Today, we're introducing
Nexus 7.
[APPLAUSE]
And here it is-- music, movies,
books, magazines,
apps, and games.
All the great content from
Google Play, right at your
fingertips.
Randall is snapping
some photos here.
And you'll notice that there's
a new animation of the photo
flying out to the right.
Words appear, even though
I don't have
a connection period.
Who is the prime minister
of Japan?
DEVICE SPEAKING: The prime
minister of Japan
is Yoshihiko Noda.
[APPLAUSE]
Watch what happens now when
Randall moves that widget to
this screen.
We've got this newer Storms game
here that you play with
your brain waves.
And you just click the
button here and--
DEVICE SPEAKING: Activity
resumed.
We do a thing called sorting by
agony, which is to say that
we don't strictly sort by price
because we consider your
time worth something.
It's 12-foot tall animatronic
human face.
These flying vehicles are
collaborating to throw a ball
up in the air and then
collaborating to
move and catch it.
And you can create all different
types of events,
everything from picnics
and barbecues to
weddings and even concerts.
If I wanted to buy one of these,
can I go buy one today
at the store?
We hope to make them
affordable.
As I mentioned, this can
be a $100 robot.
You see the familiar
Google search box.
You also see a beautiful header
that changes based on
your time and location.
And I can also scroll down
and tap on See Inside.
Once I do, I'm inside the bar.
I've got this nice view.
And for an even better
experience, I can turn on
Compass mode.
So why don't you go ahead
and do that, Randall.
[APPLAUSE]
And this is the first device
that ships with Chrome as the
standard browser.
It's pretty cool that my friends
can now play their
music in my living room.
We created Glass so that you can
interact with the virtual
world without distracting
you from the real world.
You have to want to be on the
bleeding edge, and that's what
this is really designed for.
So tell me now-- who wants
to see a demo of Glass?
[CHEERS]
All right.
This is the hangout
from Glass.
Whoa!
Look at that.
And they're off.
[CHEERS AND CLAPPING]
All right.
Let's see if we can get
it here in a hurry.
Yeah, woohoo!
Wait, wait, wait, whoa, whoa,
whoa, whoa,whoa, whoa!
No, no, no we're on the third--
OK.
[LAUGHTER]
Don't run anybody over.
Please stay in your
seats, folks.
Don't get into the aisles.
Yeah, woo!
And when your boss comes to you
and says, hey, we're going
to jump out of an airplane.
We're going to land on the roof
of Moscone and then we're
going to bike it in, you must
be working at Google.
It was really exciting to see
something that magical.